en ce public que continue avec ces mots
qu'on a employé hier et encore
aujourd'hui motion de censure
dissolution 49,3 référendum pour
comprendre les enjeux des prochaines
semaines au parlement il faut les
expertises de constitutionnalistes des
spécialistes du droit ils seront les
invités dans deux minutes et pour lancer
second débat en lice avec jérôme radier
justement ces armes institutionnels dont
dispose le président de la république
finie la présidence jupitérienne et les
décisions qui tombe d'en haut emmanuel
macron devra compter avec le parlement
pour faire avancer ses réformes à sa
disposition plusieurs outils comme
l'idée d'une coalition de gouvernement
et rejeté par les autres partis chaque
texte fera l'objet d'âpres négociations
qu'il va falloir négocier en amont comme
on était en allemagne comme on le fait
en italie chaque décision chaque projet
de loi avant de faire des grandes
annonces grandiloquentes donc ça ça
change fondamentalement pas seulement la
façon de gouverner d' emmanuel macron
mais en réalité la configuration du
présidentialisme on le connaît au moins
depuis le début du quinquennat faute
d'accord en amont des textes le fameux
article 49 alinéa 3 pourra être utilisé
mais seulement sur un projet de loi par
session en plus des textes budgétaires
le 49-3 al'avantage d'obliger les
oppositions à se prononcer mais reste
risqué c'est une arme qui concourent au
débat parlementaire et qui considère le
texte comme adopté sauf à ce que une
motion de censure soit déposé si la
motion de censure est adoptée alors le
texte est rejeté
si au contraire la notion d'intention ne
n'est pas adoptée alors le texte lui est
considéré comme adopté le président de
la république a aussi le pouvoir de
passer par référendum en demandant
directement aux français de se prononcer
mais sur des sujets précis en cas de
blocage durable ou de motion de censure
adoptée emmanuel macron pourrait aussi
dissoudre l'assemblée une solution tout
aussi périlleuse le risque qu'une
dissolution c'est évidemment que
l'assemblée pour emmanuel macron lui
reviennent encore plus opposés à lui que
la présente assemblée malgré tout il a
la possibilité de tenir un gouvernement
minoritaire qui comme elle l'est pour
faire passer certains textes l'exécutif
pourrait aussi sur certaines décisions
passées par décret en évitant le
parlement comme par exemple sur le
montant du smic mais impossible sur le
long terme de gouverner sans trouver de
majorité sur les projets de loi ce qui
promet d'intenses négociations et
quelques revirements
voilà qui pose les enjeux de notre
second débat autour de cette question la
france est-elle vraiment ingouvernable
j'accueille anne levade bonsoir cette
juriste professeur à l'université paris
1 dominique rousseau bonsoir choir
professeur de droit constitutionnel à
cette même université paris 1 auteur de
six thèse pour la démocratie continue
c'est aux éditions odile jacob jean
pierre mignard a bon soit vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris et docteur en
droit il est ici à cuba est resté à mes
côtés peut-être cette question générale
anne levade que j'ai pour ouvrir le
débat la france est-elle ingouvernable
peut-être que ça dépend tout simplement
d opposition alors ça dépend à
l'évidence du comportement que vont
avoir les oppositions c'est vraiment la
raison pour laquelle je pense que la
semaine que nous vivons est une semaine
cruciale en tout cas qu'ils devraient
l'être parce que c'est le moment avec
comme date limite l'installation des
organes de travail
de l'assemblée la semaine prochaine
c'est le moment où les oppositions
doivent s'interroger sur la manière dont
elles vont jouer leur rôle de
parlementaire
s'opposer frontalement voté contre tous
finalement c'est très facile pas très
constructif et donc puisque ce sont
souvent qui plus est des formations
politiques qui se plaignaient de ne pas
avoir d' élus et bien elles sont au pied
du mur et donc elles vont pouvoir nous
montrer qu'elles savent inventé la
manière de gouverner en majorité
relative est un peu d'ironie dans votre
camp même nom mais je moi je fais partie
de ceux qui n'ont jamais été favorable à
ce qu'on change le mode de scrutin et je
trouve intéressant là de constater que
ça n'est pas le mode de scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours qui était
responsable de l'absence de certaines
formations à l'assemblée c'est le fait
que l'élection était organisée dans des
circonscriptions et bien si les
formations politiques n'avaient pas
d'ancrage local dans un nombre
significatif de circonscription
effectivement elle n'avait pas d'élu
donc c'est plus un problème territorial
si j'ose dire qu'un problème de mode de
scrutin en tant que tel dominique
rousseau est ce que c'est cette séquence
qu'on est en train de vivre on peut
positiver c'est l'occasion d'apprendre
ou de réapprendre
le parlementarisme l'art du compromis
politique etc
absolument souvenez-vous ans se
plaignait de 2 d'un parlement qui
suivait aveuglément l'exécutif on se
plaignait de des majorités absolues qui
diminuait le rôle du parlement on va
quand même pas se plaindre maintenant
d'un parlement où il n'y a pas de
majorité de majorité absolue et ça va
nous apprendre quoi ça ou ça devrait
nous apprendre ça devrait nous apprendre
à négocier à faire des concessions à
faire des compromis qui ne soient pas
des propos qui ne sont pas des
compromissions c'est le lot de tous les
régimes parlementaires en allemagne en
italie en espagne au tour de autour de
nous aucun parti en allemagne par
exemple la majorité faut quand même
remettre les choses à plat il y a en
france aujourd'hui des minorités et une
majorité la majorité est relative mais
elle est majoritaire et il y à des
minorités et par conséquent la pratique
parlementaire tous tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui au parlement se plaignait de
la majorité absolue se plaignait d'un
gouvernement jupitérien et bien
maintenant à eux de faire la
démonstration qu'ils savent pratiquer la
forme parlementaire en construisant ce
qu'edgar fort appelait des majorités
d'idées c'est à dire texte sur texte
négocié des désaccords en fonction du
contenu du texte jean pierre mignard est
ce que cette hypothèse vous ives où la
pensée la plus probable où est ce que
vous imaginez plutôt qu'en s'oriente
vers un blocage ou si j'essaye
d'exagérer le cas où on reste dix
nominés puisque diane je suis beaucoup
plus sceptiques que moi savant bon ce
qui justifie autorisons scepticisme moi
j'étais quand même longue partie de ma
vie politique engagée chez michel rocard
et jacques delors j'étais toujours pour
des coalitions et le modèle allemand
j'étais très falloir sauf que c'était
dans des périodes où la société est
infiniment moins clivé où les
oppositions étaient beaucoup moins
heurté ou les hostilités n'étaient pas
aussi prégnante que ça un programme
comme le dit dominique en allemagne est
un programme qui prend quelques mois et
en général il est appliqué ce qui est
d'autant plus remarquable mais entre des
forces qui pour l'essentiel
sont dans un pacte démocratique qui
respecte par exemple au les forces alors
guy link mais surtout la fdr qu'un
député démocrate chrétien aurait été
autorisé à tenir les propos que certains
même ancien marcheur que j'ai connus
mais j'étais marcheurs ont tenu sur le
rassemblement national les départs
possibles une seconde donc on est dans
une situation française passée les
gaulois je sais pas si ce matin' mais
elle est infiniment plus clivée ce qui
fait que le paradigme vertueux illustré
par anne et
dominique est le meilleur qu'on puisse
espérer je crains malheureusement je le
dis que ce soit trop tard oui mais les
scènes sont que des mots nous parler des
positions compris les marcheurs contre
les rassemblements nationalistes ne sont
que des mots non pour là on laisse pas
passer les dernières les oppositions
dont on parle est bien content oui c'est
oui mais des mots vous savez en
politique les moussanais important
mais il ya quand même il ya quand même
c'est pour ça que je disais il ya une
majorité et des minorités oui c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même les électeurs
ont envoyé une majorité oui au québec
aeterna d'angoumé en disant c'est une
claque c'est honorifique il ya quand
même une majorité mais il ya quand même
une majorité à l'assemblée et évidemment
les oppositions par exemple on entendait
jean luc mélenchon les français n'ont
pas approuvé le smic à 1500 euros et
sinon il aurait été majoritaire donc
qu'il y est
le programme de
de la république en mars enfin deux
ensembles qui soit le socle à partir
duquel on va créer des négociations avec
les autres partis politiques c'est ce
qui se fait partout alors oui un risque
de blocage parce que nous avons une
culture bonapartiste nous avons pas une
culture du compromis et de la
négociation c'est ce qui s'est passé
alors on parlait de l'allemagne mais il
ya l'espagne l'espagne a connu comme
nous la bipolarisation lépi d'un seul
coup le parlement fragmenté résultat il
ya eu trois dissolutions à quatre ans
mais aujourd'hui un gouvernement il ya
on peut même donner trois exemples je
vous donnais à la part le tout de suite
laetitia puisqu'il ya l'espagne
l'allemagne ses pays confrontés nos
voisins l'absence de majorité absolue et
aussi l'italie on va les voir s'afficher
l'italie gouvernement présidé par mario
draghi depuis un an et demi un tiers de
ministres techniques de tir de miss
politique ça va de la gauche à l'extrême
droite l'espagne a parlé des socialistes
et polemos et puis l'allemagne
évidemment ça a été beaucoup commentée
coalition sociaux démocrates écologistes
et les libéraux laetitia c'est sévère
vers quoi on s'oriente plutôt vers un
un accord de gouvernement ou alors du
des négociations et des discussions
texte par texte il semblerait qu
emmanuel macron s'inspire de lui-même
encore une fois rappelez vous quand il
était ministre de l'économie il avait
été négocié ça avait été beaucoup comme
on dit ce taux rester les raconter ils
avaient été négociés individuellement en
passant des nuits à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien apparemment ce serait
la feuille de route qui auraient été
donnés aux nouveaux députés arrivant à
l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire que
l'on gros on essaiera négocier texte par
texte la retraite on a entendu christian
jacob nous dit qu'ils pourraient voter
le texte pour la retraite à 65 ans on
aurait plutôt un accord avec l ère pour
le pouvoir d'achat pourquoi pas un
accord avec socialiste
peut-être sociaux-démocrates et puis
aussi les écologistes en voyez vous ce
sera vraiment texte par texte et ce sera
un peu peut-être députés par député pour
comprendre un peu la situation va
écouter clément boon qui lui a sauvé son
siège il était ce matin sur lci
la question va être d'inventer quelque
chose qui va permettre au delà du
théâtre politique 1 votre réelle ça va
redonner c'était d'ailleurs un des
messages que nous disaient les uns les
autres le rassemblement national ils
étaient dix ans pour la proportionnelle
monsieur mélenchon il disait il faut
redonner le pouvoir au parlement bon ils
n'ont pas réussi leur pari mais dont
tact le parlement va devenir la reine
central du jeu politique français
peut-être plus et peut-être que c'est
pas si mal encore une fois c'est assez
surprenant parce qu'il dit va falloir
inventer quelque chose le parlement va
de manière la reine centrale oui enfin
c'était déjà le cas c'est peut-être le
maquereau nice mme kivell oublié comment
fonctionner nos institutions comprend
quand même que ça va être compliqué pour
le gouvernement de s'y mettre et qu'il
faudra aller comme je vous le disais
peut-être convaincre un par un oui alors
jusqu'où effet ce qu'évoquait le permis
à tout à l'heure jusqu'au rassemblement
national oui parce que c'est un des
enseignements de ce scrutin le front
républicain wii est mort alors il
n'existe peut-être encore pour
l'élection présidentielle mais pour les
autres élections il n'existe plus et
donc on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas
vraiment de limite dans ces accords et
pour bien comprendre on va ré écouter
eric dupond moretti en a parlé tout à
l'heure qui était sur le plateau de
bfmtv c'était dimanche soir plutôt que
de critiquer par exemple le bilan
justice on vous verra je le dis sans
forfanterie au pied du mur
c'est au pied du mur qu'on voit le maçon
c'est en réalité on à l'assemblée
nationale que nous verrons et que nos
compatriotes verrons comment nous
essayons d'avancer ensemble
c'est peut-être le tour s'adresse un
représentant du rassemblement
international et c'est peut-être le
tournant dans notre vème république
l'incorporation définitive du
rassemblement national dans nos
institutions et de ses idées dans le
débat public comment vous réagi anne
levade en entendant eric dupond-moretti
faire cet appel du pied est ce que vous
vous dites on est un soir d'élection
c'est un séisme politique les éléments
de langage ont pas été transmis par tous
ou est ce que vous y voyez finalement 1
parler de barrage républicain la énième
fissures où l'effondrement total de ce
barrage républicain alors je crois que
le gouvernement comme d'ailleurs toutes
les formations politiques qui
aujourd'hui ont des élus à l'assemblée
nationale sont devant une réalité c'est
que le front national à un nombre très
important de députés
quoi que l'on pense de ses idées le fait
est que il va bien falloir d'une manière
ou d'une autre les associer au quotidien
au travail parlementaire puisque il fait
aucun doute que le rassemblement
national aura un groupe parlementaire je
rappelle que toutes les instances de
l'assemblée nationale sont
formés à la proportionnelle des groupes
donc ça signifie qu'ils vont avoir des
membres dans toutes les commissions au
sein du bureau etc et donc il y à un
moment où par la force des choses ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'on ne combattent pas
les idées mais il va bien falloir quand
même travaillé avec ses députés là aussi
faut dire aussi qu'en même que
l'habitude a été prise en parlement
européen aujourd'hui je ne crois pas que
grand monde s'émeuvent de ce que des
députés qui sont issus du rassemblement
national ou de formation comparable
d'autres pays européens siège et
participe aux discussions une autre
chose est de voir dans quel sens ils
votent et le type d'amendements qui ne
sont susceptibles de déposer jean pierre
mignard
cette séquence pour vous elle marque une
rupture as une trahison moral je veux
pas la qualifier autrement parce que
c'était une question de justice cette
sécurité or le programme le faut le
rassemblement national à un programme
très particulier en matière de justice
est sécurité et sur ce point en effet
c'est une rupture à peu près complète
avec pompe avec un peu près tout ce
qu'il nous reste des dispositions de 45
vous a surpris pendant interrompre de la
part d'une hausse un film monsieur le
ministre est en position extrêmement
difficile à titre personnel donc il a
fait une campagne d'une grande violence
conclure assemblée nationale quand il
était dans le nord il a d'ailleurs subi
une très grande défaite à la hauteur de
sa très grande violence et maintenant je
le vois à tendre des perches le racing
en national donc j'ai plutôt le
sentiment d'une perdition que d'autres
choses mais par exemple dames le pen sur
la peine de mort n'a oublié des top 10
mais moi je ne veux pas à faire deux par
contre je veux un débat assez très
habile parce que le compromis qu'elle a
passé c'est sur la peine de mort il faut
qu'on a eu des barris alors par exemple
si on cherche un rapprochement avec leur
assemblée nationale est-ce qu'on va
organiser un débat ça va nous manger
parce que ça débat chez comment ils
commencent je sais pas où il termine on
va faire un débat sera mieux j'ai plein
d'exemples pas reprendre ça alors ça ça
pose en effet un certain nombre de
questions sur d'autres points oui
pourquoi pas mais sur ces questions là
qu'ils sont majeurs qui touchent au
pacte démocratique opaque américain à
nos engagements en matière de co2
européens de droits de l'homme attention
je dis non et là je dis c'est la ligne
rouge et là je dis ce serait une
trahison moral et dominique rousseau
seront toujours si les limites de la
deûle à gaudi on pourrait appeler ça
comme ça c'est à dire un texte où on va
chercher une majorité à droite voire
jusqu'au rassemblement national et puis
un autre on va aller chercher une
majorité peut être vert le parti
socialiste quelques dissidents qui n'ont
pas voulu de la nuque oui mais c'est le
commerce et la pratique parlementaire
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de coalition en
allemagne il ya une colle aucun parti
n'a la majorité absolue sur donc le spd
les libéraux et les écologistes ont fait
une alliance ils ont mis deux mois pour
faire leur alliance est une coalition
dont il ya un gouvernement partagé et
ils appliquent leurs programmes comme
comme comme il est jean-pierre bon
visiblement on ne va pas vers cette
hypothèse là on va plutôt vers une
hypothèse texte par texte donc comment
ça va se passer vraisemblablement le
gouvernement présentera un projet de loi
et puis après il y aura des négociations
avec les différents groupes qui vont
accepter des amendements patrick pas
accepter des amendements jusqu'où ça ira
c'est là on sera plus lent çà çà çà çà
sera plus lent ça c'est le régime
parlementaire on peut pas à la fois on
peut pas à la fois ce comment dire
critiqué le présidentialisme et les
majorité absolue qui bloque le débat on
peut pas à la fois critiquer la majorité
absolue et elle dira maintenant avec la
majorité relative à être plus lent mais
cela est plus lent parce que c'est la
démocratie est lente sinon céder ou case
donc la démocratie c'est lent et les il
faudra construire texte par textes ou
des majorités il y aura peut-être un
blocage mais s'il ya blocage c'est
simple dissolution on va en parler
l'addition elle va se lier à un mot plus
lent et plus paradoxalement oui la
gueule parce que ça a été négocié non
mais la question de la lenteur de la
discussion du texte ne me semble pas
problématique parce que bien souvent on
a des textes qui ont été adoptés
beaucoup trop rapidement et dont on
s'aperçoit a posteriori que soit ils ne
sont pas de la qualité escompté soit
parfois d'ailleurs il n'était pas
indispensable parce que n'est pas
interdit de penser que si la discussion
de chaque loi prend beaucoup plus de
temps et d'énergie en termes de
négociations
peut-être il y aura aussi moins de texte
est d'ailleurs français sont pas
indispensables souvent les décrets
d'application les attend encore oui et
de ce point de vue là le fêter aussi et
c'est sans doute ce qui sera le plus
difficile pour emmanuel macron pour le
peu que je perçois de sa personnalité ce
qui est clair c'est que ça va être
l'anti ce pan de son action prenons un
exemple nul n'imagine avec cette
configuration là qui lui sera aisé par
exemple de demander à pouvoir adopter
des ordonnances là je pense qu'on est
clairement alors que ça a été pour lui
un mode de gouvernement sur les derniers
mois on est clairement dans un schéma
qui est impossible alors on peut
peut-être rappeler on fait de la
pédagogie dans cette émission donc ça
c'est effectivement l'un des leviers que
la constitution offre auprès de la
république c'est quoi exactement dans
quel cadre il peut les utiliser une
ordonnance alors tels que l'article 38
de la constitution prévoit les
ordonnances c'est pour l'exécution du
programme du gouvernement de fait et
dans la pratique c'est toujours sur
l'impulsion du président de la
république et lorsque d'ailleurs on a eu
l'expérience en cohabitation d'un
premier ministre qui voulait faire
passer par ordonnance des réformes il a
pu arriver que le président de la
république je pense à la première
cohabitation en 86 refuse de la signer
l'idée est donc que pour l'exécution de
son programme est très clairement pour
aller plus vite le gouvernement demande
au parlement de l'habilité dont de
l'autoriser pendant une durée déterminée
a entre guillemets légiférer à sa place
c'est-à-dire a adopté sans débat
parlementaire un texte qui ensuite devra
faire l'objet d'une ratification
législatives donc reviendra mais
toujours sans débat pour que les
parlementaires acceptent que cela reste
une loin
jean pierre mignard
le dans les hypothèses on en a évoqué
plusieurs on a évoqué l'hypothèse du
blocage on a évoqué l'hypothèse de
l'accord au cas par cas ou alors de
l'accord de gouvernement ça c'est les
trois grandes familles on peut dire ça
comme ça si je me place dans l'hypothèse
du blocage et là on est un peu dans la
stratégie suis pas non plus dans la tête
d'emmanuel matheron mais la stratégie
c'est de laisser un peu la situation
pourrir pourrais éventuellement décider
d'une dissolution après c'est là aussi
je crois nous sommes en politique donc
le ce n'est pas un balle et harmonieux
la vie politique il ya des adversaires
il ya des opportunités et des
circonstances il est exact que si par
exemple une opposition par exemple
l'opposition de gauche et du nouveau en
difficulté et si le parlement fonctionne
de manière très difficile le président
peut considérer que c'est le moment
dissoudre et qui peut espérer une
nouvelle majorité le contraire est tout
aussi vrai car le président peut se
retrouver de nouveau avec une majorité
qui lui soit hostile et dans ces cas là
je cède devant devant anne et dominique
serait il faudrait donc dans ces cas il
peut pas il peut par 10 ou doit vendre
bah oui disons un nom alors à
l'éducation soit la torche et les laissa
pas ce que c'est
et on va même expliqué avec jérémie
hoffmann qui va se retrouver avec un
exercice difficile nous expliquer
comment fonctionne la dessiner la
dissolution face à deux éminent
constitutionnaliste
me
racontez nous comment ça fonctionne sa
dissolution ça pourrait être un outil
pour emmanuel macron parce qu'avec la
majorité relative la plus faible de la
vème république dans une assemblée que
certains qualifient on l'a dit déjà d'un
gouvernable le chef de l'état pourrait
faire appel à l'article 12 de la
constitution
selon cet article le président de la
république peut après consultation du
premier ministre et des présidents des
deux assemblées prononcer la dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale les élections
générales ont lieu 20 jours au moins et
quarante jours au plus après la
dissolution et il ne peut être procédé à
une nouvelle dissolution dans l'année
qui suit ces élections autrement dit
s'il y a eu dix solutions puis des
élections il faut donc attendre un an
avant de pouvoir effectuer une nouvelle
dissolution mais après des élections
législatives classiques comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui rien n'empêche le
président de la république de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale il pourrait donc
le faire à tout moment après avoir
consulté elisabeth bornes gérard larcher
et le ou la future présidente de
l'assemblée nationale interrogé hier la
porte parole du gouvernement olivier
grégoire a assuré qu'une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale n'est pour
l'instant pas prévu est-ce que c'est
aussi un risque politique oui il imagine
alors ça pour en parler pour s'en rendre
compte on peut essayer de faire un point
historique sous la vème république on
compte au total 5 dissolution les deux
premières sous le général de gaulle en
1962 pour sortir d'une crise politique
et en 1968 pour faire face à une crise
nationale et dans les deux cas les
gaullistes obtienne la majorité absolue
de dissolution également sous françois
mitterrand à une époque en fait tous les
élections législatives n'avaient pas
lieu dans la foulée de l'élection
présidentielle et en 1987 une réussite
mais en 1988 le chef de l'état doit se
contenter d'une majorité relative et
dernière dissolution en 1997 sous
jacques chirac le président est élu
depuis deux ans mais il n'a plus de
majorité solide à l'assemblée donc il
l'a dit sous mais la dissolution est un
échec à la boutique sur une victoire de
la gauche et 50 cohabitation avec lionel
jospin donc la dissolution vous l'aurez
compris elle pourrait être risqué pour
emmanuel
rond et s'ils y avaient recours ce
serait en tout cas une première depuis
l'instauration du quinquennat en 2002 et
le couplage des élections présidentielle
et législatives merci jérémy pour tous
ces détails à anne levade ya une
subtilité qui alors je vous l'avoué
humblement m'avait échappé c'est ce
délai d'un an
là on est on est pas dans ce délai d'un
an non et même à qu'on peut dissoudre
demain là assurément pas dans ce cas de
figure parce que si on relit bien
l'alinéa qui a été remarquablement citer
les bien parler d'une nouvelle
dissolution sera donc forcément une
dissolution sur dissolution après ces
élections dont celles qui ont eu lieu
après une dissolution la raison en est
simple c'est que la dissolution peut pas
être un mode de gouvernement on peut pas
avoir un président qui à chaque fois
qu'un texte n'est pas voté ce dimanche
je me débarrasse de cette assemblée on
va en trouver une nouvelle de la même
manière d'ailleurs que quand le
président dise où il n'a pas la maîtrise
du calendrier des élections qui suivent
là aussi la constitution impose que
l'élection ait lieu dans les 20 à 40
jours qui suivent pour qu'un président
ne soient pas tentés de se passer de
l'assemblée puisque finalement c'est
quand même bien contrariant flatteur
mais en gros soit ils arrivent à avoir
une majorité absolue après avoir dissout
soit il perd et donc il est forcé à la
cohabitation alors soit il a une
majorité absolue pour lui ou quelqu'un
il a remporté le pari soit il ya une
majorité absolue contre lui mais avec
une formation ou une coalition qui est
en capacité de gouverner parce que elle
a seul la majorité absolue et donc la
cohabitation soit on est dans la
situation qu'on connaît aujourd'hui où
il a une majorité relative à une
démission enfin la fin à une démission
si la nouvelle assemblée président
l'accusé on revient il y aura
aujourd'hui lionel messi les d'une
association réaliste de l'est
maison
gaullisme vous effraie pas ça n'est pas
patron d'alors mais ça n'est pas imposé
de qui là c'est selon mais s'il ya une d
une dissolution puis d'accord une
nouvelle une nouvelle assemblée revient
avec cette assemblée est encore plus
plus plus je suis celle ci je pense que
le président ne peut que prendre acte de
ce que c'est la chirac n'a pas
démissionné mais jacques chirac avait
fait en faire un nom souple
il ya un élément il ya un élément je
crois qu'il faut qu'il faut introduire
ce qu'elle me donne là qu'on ne peut pas
se représenter représenter tous les
prisonniers et par conséquent les
alliances au cas par cas va être aussi
comment dire examinée de manière
subliminale par le fait que alors il ne
pourra pas être candidat tombe déjà
c'est intéressant de faire un peu quand
même c'est de la politique fiction mais
non il peut pas se représenter mais s'il
démissionnait maintenant à il a pas fait
un second mandat complet à ce que est ce
qu'il pourrait éventuellement se
représenter grande controverse le dire
autres les constitutionnalistes on
pourrait considérer on pourrait
considérer qu' il n'a pas fait deux fois
cinq ans donc il pourrait se représenter
mais je suis sûr que d'autres collègues
défendons l'idée que ben tant pis c'est
accompagné de jésus
je rappelle que c'est pas
mandat quoi qu'il arrive dans toute sa
vie non ces deux mandats
il est donc tout à fait possible et
reviens d'engendrer un quinquennat pour
pourquoi pas revenir oui alors je mens
quand même d'écouter juste les des
petites idées qui sort de l'elysée et la
ja de frace emmanuel macron et serein et
il réfléchit la suite oui je pense pas
qu'il démissionne n'engage pas ça il va
pas démissionner tout de suite ça c'est
sûr mais personne n'y croyait pour
réaliser que c'était la politique
fiction mais il ya très balisé mais si
c'est le père vite et le la nouvelle
configuration pourrait aussi conduire au
moins momentanément mais ça c'est de là
qu'est ce c'est une question comment des
erreurs stratégiques à maître emmanuel
macron en retrait parce que si on va
vers un fonctionnement parlementaire
comme certains le souhaitent selon le
type qui va avoir du pouvoir et les
présidents nouveau le ministre des
relations avec le parlement et le
président de l'assemblée nationale parce
que c'est là que vont se construire les
majorités mais je reviens jean-pierre
bien sûr aurait sur cette idée de
dissolution et on a évoqué le précédent
jacques chirac 97 c'est je pense la
hantise des manuels macron en tout cas
c'était ce qu'on disait avant le
résultat de ces dix là tu y vas un
second quinquennat pour rien en quelque
sorte écouter un grand inconnu de notre
discussion y compris pour lui compris
ces oppositions gruss à ma journée c'est
l'événement 1 quels sont les événements
qui vont se produire quels sont les
événements qui vont amener les lits
dirigeants politiques peut-être dans des
situations catastrophiques ou dramatique
par exemple à monsieur madame mâcon
d'appeler monsieur jean luc mélenchon
non pas pour nous approvisionner la
situation devient extrêmement grave pour
le pays je veux vous rencontrer parce
que je veux que nous parlions les ça
serait donc on aura dans une situation
qui est celle que nous connaissons les
guerres la question climatique des
crises financières qui tôt ou tard se
produiront etc vous aurez a évidemment
des bouleversements internes qui seront
telles que les architectures politiques
qui sont du clavecin de la partition
jouée par mes amis professeurs et dans
le tas leur est considérable un moment
donné c'est tout et tout et bouleversant
vous dit que la politique prend le
dessus sur la évidemment la considère
heureusement pardon mais eux ils sont
très forts pour nous rassurer quand la
politique je dirais pas que c'est le lac
léman est là mais quand ça bouleverse
évidemment il faut que les gens se
parlent et c'est ce qui est peut-être
devant nous mais met d'ailleurs on peut
parce que c'est intéressant de
d'analyser le degré de souplesse de
notre constitution finalement pour pour
répondre à ces crises pour donner de la
marge de manoeuvre à l'exécutif anne
levade alors moi je suis intimement
convaincu que contrairement à ce qu'on
dit parfois on n'est pas face à une
crise de régime
la preuve bien que scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours on a finalement seulement une
majorité relative est par ailleurs il ya
toute une série d'instruments dans la
constitution qui ont été conçus en 1958
à un moment où on n'imaginait pas le
fait majoritaire donc des mécanismes qui
permettent au gouvernement de sécuriser
sa position quand bien même il aurait
une majorité relative je ne prends qu'un
exemple la motion de censure le vote à
la motion de censure donne lieu à un
décompte dans lequel les abstentions
sont comptabilisés avec les voix ou
soutien du gouvernement ce qui veut donc
dire que seuls les députés qui demandent
le départ du gouvernement sont
identifiés ça change beaucoup la donne
pourquoi parce que sous la quatrième
république s'était pas le cas on
identifiait les trois types de vote et
donc dans ce cas là on disait ab il ya
150 voix
contre mais seulement 120 pour le
gouvernement donc c'est une majorité
relative contre le gouvernement alors
même que la constitution exigé qu'il y
ait une majorité absolue contre le
gouvernement sauf que le gouvernement
était fragilisée et il partait en 58 on
a déterminé dans la configuration que je
viens de décrire et je suis pas très
bonne en maths donc je reste sur mes
chiffres simplificateur 150 contre et
bien saint-nexans 50 sur 577 tous les
autres qu'ils se soient abstenus ou
lille j'ai dit oui sont réputées
soutenir le gouverneur cinq ans il faut
râler dans le maison allait dans le sens
de dan faut pas oublier que de 58 à 62
il n'y avait pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale il y avait des
couilles du coup d'état militaire il y
avait des goûts et à l'elysée on a une
constitution qui est quand même assez
souple et ce qu'elle a connu la guerre
d'algérie mai 68 les cohabitations bon
on a tous connu donc elle elle possède
effectivement les éléments permettant de
s'adapter à toutes les situations y
compris la situation actuelle et celle
encore une fois où il ya une majorité et
des minorités faut pas l'oublier et en
52 58 à 62 il n'y avait pas de majorité
absolue pour le général de gaulle s'est
terminée comment ça s'est terminé par le
vote d'une motion de censure
parce que là les oppositions ont voté le
même texte contre le général mentionné
général de gaulle il y à une dissolution
et il ya une majorité absolue pour le
général de gaulle donc si vous voulez le
la dissolution est une arme que garde le
président de la république et ça se
jouera devant l'opinion qui portera la
responsabilité du blocage est ce que
l'opinion publique rendra responsables
du blocage les oppositions qui n'ont pas
voulu jouer le jeu parlementaire alors
qu elle le demandait ou est-ce que le
pignon rendra responsables emmanuel
macron qui n'a pas fait suffisamment de
concessions pour arriver pour
relativiser les oppositions et voir
comment on peut fonctionner la vie
publique dans le cadre des institutions
la gauche manifestent contre françois
mitterrand 58 mitterrand écrit le coup
d'état permanent il ya des centaines de
milliers de gens mendès-france l'élu
communiste mitterrand qui manifestent
contre lui c'est la détestation absolue
puis il ya le coup d'état militaire est
alors la gauche se range aux côtés du
général de gaulle et malraux d'imams il
faut armer la gauche selon effectivement
ses souvenirs de la guerre d'espagne
donc vous voyez que quand je dis que
l'événement commandes je me tiens
d'accord mais quand on regarde la crise
sanitaire et la façon dont on a décidé
de tout emmanuel macron avec ce conseil
de défense qu'il est totalement opaque
et il y avait bien à chaque fois des
textes proposés à l'assemblée où ils
allaient ce que on aurait la même tu
n'étais même type de gouvernance
aujourd'hui avec l'assemblée
d'aujourd'hui je pense que oui parce que
je pense que l'urgence a encore une fois
l'événement et l'urgence commanderont
voilà nous avons une assemblée qui
serait consitue considère constituée de
personnes ayant perdu à moitié le bon
sens ce qui n'est pas envisageable c'est
encore pire que les appartenances
politiques les gens qui n'ont plus le
sens des choses écrit alors c'est le
seul pari qu'on puisse faire ce sont des
choses n'oublions pas que derrière les
électeurs qu'ils voient tous les jours
mais sur le passage du service vous
enfin ça fonctionne et sa fonction
si on prend votre sillon plan au type
d'ailleurs le la crise sanitaire prix
riquiqui redémarre le prénom république
qui remet en place le conseil de défense
alors là effectivement il peut y avoir
une motion de censure déposée par les
oppositions et les comment dire la
motion de censure peut être votée à la
majorité absolue des membres de
l'assemblée nationale bon
et jeudi celle ci a pas d'incident
l'hypothèse que vous soulevez on
pourrait considérer par exemple si on
prend des positions de marine le pen de
jean luc mélenchon était contre 10
contre ils pourraient ensemble sur ces
deux là où ça c'est celle là on est plus
au puy pour moi simplement dans le nom
l'analyse politique
je vais aller au bout de ma cuisine son
prix charles bardon mai
c'est ce qui risque de se passer quand
même là avec l'émotion de sens auxerre
on va voir une alliance je le dis rouge
- pour employer des termes anciens mais
bon c'est quand même une possibilité le
conseil de défense par exemple s'il
devait malheureusement se réunir de
nouveau parce qu'il y aurait une
nouvelle
agression épidémiologique dans ce cas là
il s'agit d'associer les trois ou quatre
grandes familles du parlement construit
doit défendre et on les fait rentrer
mais oui c'est à dire contre et cèdent
pas ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé là donc
quand même été quand même mise à côté
alors déjà sont à bout ils ont un
caractère donc on sait on s'est cabré et
donc je pense que alors c'est peut-être
là où la nouvelle pratique politique
peut être effectivement d'ailleurs tout
à fait se marier avec la constitution la
lettre et l'esprit c'est à dire qu'on
précède qu'on associe on parle et qu'on
trouve des accords et voilà ça alors ça
c'est une nouvelle formule où le
président n'est plus simple mais plus
simplement le primus inter pares s et
les celui qui s'est un facilitateur
alors vous avez en partie répondu à la
question que j'ai quand même donné la
parole à l'un des chefs de file de la
france insoumise c'est le député du nord
réélu adrien cat-nat ce qui relance
cette idée de 6ème république on a le
bloc ultra libérale avec emmanuel macron
le bloc identitaire d'extrême droite
comme ça je le qualifie avec madame le
pen et ce bloc populaire que nous avons
rassemblés mais incontestablement nos
institutions elle elle prévoit la
confrontation entre deux blocs donc il
ya un problème il ya un problème avec
les institutions de la vème république
sur le papier avec ce que nous avons
sous les yeux le pays est ingouvernable
c'est dans une logique de coalition
alors on écoutait aller 1-4 menacé en
même temps les siècles pas me disais qu
edward fipa l'instant dit que la
majorité doit se placer dans une logique
de coalition à l'assemblée c'est
intéressant d'entendre l'ancien premier
ministre est quand même
encore importants efforts aujourd'hui et
qui peut-être sera amené à le devenir
encore plus dans les mois et les années
à venir on verra bien prendre cette
position là dominique rousseau
6ème république vous avez en partie
répondu à la question il y en a pas
besoin la constitution elle n'a pas
besoin et je comprends pas le le
commentaire du député de la française
ont misé parce que justement ce zidane
tout à l'heure de la constitution n'a
pas été fait pour deux blocs la
constitution a été fait pour permettre
précisément que des constructions
majoritaire se fasse dans l'hypothèse où
il n'y aurait pas de majorité absolue
donc on est dans la pratique
parlementaire normale qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent dans la 6ème république la 6ème
république en réalité ce qu'ils veulent
c'est un retour au texte originel de
1958 ils veulent que le premier ministre
détermine la politique de la nation ils
veulent que le président soit en
souhaitant retrait c'est une des
possibilités que permet que permet la
cause il ya quand même un une arme de la
constitution offre qualifiée aux prises
en république on n'en a pas encore parlé
ils font parler c'est le référendum
évidemment anne levade article 11 de la
constitution vous nous rappeler ce qu'il
ce qu'il prévoit dans quel cadre on peut
l'utiliser alors la constitution prévoit
effectivement que le président de la
république peut décider d'organiser un
référendum sur l'adoption d'un projet de
loi qui porte uniquement sur certains
sujets
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics les
réformes les projets de loi relatifs aux
réformes et aux services publics qui y
concourent
ossébi économiques sociaux et
environnementaux
et en vue de l'autorisation de la
ratification d'un traité la
particularité du système c'est que là
effectivement le parlement disparaît
puisque le projet de loi est directement
soumis au peuple sans aucune
intervention parlementaire d'aucune
sorte et en particulier sans aucun
amendement possible mais je dirais que
dans le contexte là immédiat si on se
place à la date à laquelle nous sommes
je m'interroge sur la question de savoir
si le référendum n'est pas presque
encore plus dangereux pour emmanuel
macron là je me place de son point de
vue que ne le serait une dissolution
parce que finalement on est quand même
dans une configuration on l'a dit
particulière mais une configuration
qu'on a déjà connu à l'aube d'un
deuxième mandat présidentiel avec
françois mitterrand même si bien sûr il
venait d'y avoir une cohabitation
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que ça
n'est pas la même chose d'avoir en cours
de mandat présidentiel une majorité
hostile et d'avoir alors qu'on viendrait
élire un président de la république une
majorité qui n'est pas absolument
favorables pourquoi parce que et
peut-être emmanuel macron peut
l'interpréter comme cela finalement
peut-être les électeurs lui demande-t-il
de cogérer ça n'est pas de la
cohabitation mais de cogérer avec
d'autres formations politiques
le gouvernement de la france et moi j'ai
un peu le sentiment je sais que certains
se sont étonnés que ce soit lui qui
reçoivent les une présidente formation
politique aujourd'hui que c'est
peut-être l'interprétation qu'en l'état
il donne de la situation c'est-à-dire à
lui qui vient d'être réélu président de
tirer les conséquences puisqu'il est
celui qui nommera le premier ministre de
cette
configuration politique totalement
nouveau au lendemain mais bien sûr mais
c'est chaque élection mais est-ce que
c'est pas le sens de de ce que edouard
philippe a dit a dit à l'instant ce que
c'est dans une logique de coalition
qu'est ce que dit ce que dit edouard
philippe me semble-t-il parce que nous
nous rapporter je dirais c'est
l'hypothèse allemande oui c'est à dire
que le lan ensemble passe un accord de
gouvernement avec alors bon avec
mais sauf que c'est parce qu'ils avaient
été on l'a évoqué le débat je reviens je
reprends un argument de nos côtes raides
donc je lui je lui rends mais pour nos
téléspectateurs qui ont assisté à toutes
les missions c'est intéressant de vous
le rappeler sauf que c'était pas dans le
contrat de départ bien des électeurs ce
même important de le rappeler c'est même
le contraire alors ça c'est un problème
on peut changer de position dans la vie
politique si les événements l'imposent
mais je pense que vous voyez alors que
l'événement est plaisant mais
l'abstention n'est pas présente dans nos
discussions c'est à dire que cet immense
immense retrait de 2 millions de nos
concitoyens de la vie politique parce
que là finalement nous parlons à
l'assemblée de gens qui sont finalement
une minorité héroïque vertueuse dans la
république mais ils y allaient millions
et millions et là je pense que le
référendum alors c'est sur la question
parce que je pense que les délégations
les assemblée et sénat je pense que il
faut que l'initiative référendaire soit
bien travaillé mais qu'elle soit
présente dans notre république parce que
ce que vous dites qu'ils aient attention
notre notre garçon marche mal et donc si
on veut trop le faire marcher il des
référendum il va se casser la figure
c'est vrai mais votre situation le
garçon qui marche mal il reste tellement
ainsi parce qu'on a peur qu'ils tombent
qu'il va avoir des membres atrophiés et
c'est ça la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes là ce que je disais c'est que le
référendum de l'article 11 initié par
emmanuel macron à l'heure à laquelle
nous est paru accord là dessus dans la
mesure où une part importante du vote
est quand même une vote un vote contre
emmanuel je suis le gars me semble
possible entre mm
alain il ya des initiatives qui
pourraient venir autre que du président
de la république
on fragilise ont choisi lise la fonction
construire une grande coalition dans
l'intérêt du pays pour une majorité
stable et responsable sinon nous irons
vers d'énormes problèmes aux legs
exactement ce que gérard fini peu ce que
ça très bon comédien mais il n'était pas
sur les planches finit pas dit tout à
l'heure oui effectivement je pense que
c'est une des hypothèses qu'on on a
discuté ici l'hypothèse de construire
une majorité de coalition bon ça ça
pourrait marcher quel est le message que
le que les français ont envoyé si on met
de côté pour l'instant les
abstentionnistes semble-t-il les
électeurs ont dit on ne veut pas une
majorité absolue
pour emmanuel macron on veut qu emmanuel
macron est une majorité relative pour
l'amener à négocier avec les autres bon
ben allons-y allons j que ensemble
négocié avec des républicains ou avec
quelques divers gauche pour pour
construire les biens de tant de
commandes coalition parce qu'on on a vu
en allemagne ça prenait plusieurs mois
mais là mais ça peut peut être immédiat
mais ça peut être ça peut être immédiat
mais pourquoi voulez vous faire un
gouvernement il immédiatement je veux
dire aux gens en allemagne ils ont ils
ont mis pour dernières élections ils ont
mis deux mois pour faire un gouvernement
parce qu'ils voulaient faire passer des
lois avant l'été c'est pour ça les lois
pouvoir d'achat ça met du temps parce
qu'il est mais il faut programme écoutez
je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
attention on a critiqué laverty la
verticalité on a critiqué le couvert
jupitérien on a critiqué le lait
majorité absolue là avec des majorité
relative ça prend du temps c'est des
négociations et est par conséquent il
faut s'habituer à la pratique
parlementaire il ya une question que
j'ai pas posée on peut faire passer une
loi à la majorité relative sa maman si
les oppositions de
la plupart des textes de lois sont
votées à la majorité relative qu'il
aurait pu passer par là voilà et donc on
n'a jamais besoin d'avoir 289 ou plus
devoir à l'assemblée nationale pour
adopter un texte sauf que en sens
inverse on connaît aussi la pratique de
ce qu'on appelle le rideau c'est à dire
parfois les oppositions qui tout en
ayant l'air de ne pas participer à la
discussion sont au moment du vote
derrière un rideau qu'ils ouvrent pour
venir voter contre donc évidemment que
la logique de mais aussi tout les oppose
sur le papier une ispo faire tomber un
gouvernement ou les parlementaires déjà
sur une fois
faire justement ça rejoint ce que je
disais au départ c'est à dire qu'elle
est la conception qu'ils vont avoir de
l'eau rôle d'opposant et c'est là que la
majorité de projets dont texte par tex
j'ai utilisé le mot tout à l'heure et
potentiellement épuisante y compris
physiquement pour ceux qui vont être
amenés à négocier vous parliez de la loi
macron effectivement emmanuel macron l'a
fait mais on se souvient que ça va durer
des jours et des nuits des nuits alors
que a priori une coalition de
gouvernement ça permet pendant un temps
déterminé même si elle est toujours
susceptible d'exploser en vol mais quand
même d'avoir une forme de sécurité sauf
à ce que tout le monde se dédisent les
sujets merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'était
vraiment passionnant j'espère que on a
joué ce rôle de pédagogique on essaye de
tenir
régulièrement avec ou sans gérard
philipe
pendant cette cette émission merci en
tout cas à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité elles sont publiques nôtre